peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the dean show
where we try to bring you a new show
every week trying to help you understand
islam and muslims
and we've been talking about with our
next guest
sheikh yusuf estes who is a former
christian preacher
whose father was also a minister his
whole family accepted islam
and he is trying to help us and help
you guys understand islam he goes around
the world
giving wonderful talks and speeches and
we've been talking about the prophets
what they lived
what they called people to and
we talked about adam we talked about
idris we talked about
noah and we left off at abraham
now you can see our prior shows at the
dean show dot com
under shake use of essence's special
section
just click on there and if you didn't
catch the previous shows you can go
there so you can
get to where we are and what we're
talking about today so when we come back
we're going to continue talking about
the prophets their lives what they
called
the people to when we come back here on
the dean show
allah
why i did that maybe maybe it's just to
break the ice assalaamu alaikum
thank you for being with us again it's
nice to be back on
uh you know when i come up the elevator
today i was thinking
that if this place gets any taller it's
going to be close to the paradise itself
and
get a shortcut here sure you don't get
nosebleeds up this side do you no
okay i just wondered i didn't know thank
you it's always a pleasure to have you
here with us on the dean show
we've done many shows with you and
people can go to the special
section that you have on the
deanshow.com where they can see all the
other prior shows
and especially these shows that we're
doing the series about the prophets we
talked about adam we talked about
noah and abraham and we talked about the
way of life that they were on
that they all called the people to not
worship
worship what's in the creation but
worship the one who created the creation
the god
almighty alone let's continue off
continue on where we left off and that
was talking about abraham
when we were talking about the prophets
what we're talking about is
as you said what what they called people
to do
as far as the way they ran their lives
yes how do
how do you run your life because this
word in arabic is deen
that's your show it's called the dean
show the way of your life
and everybody has a deen whether or not
they're a believer because it doesn't
mean religion as some people mistakenly
translated it means
your way and there aren't many people
that have no religion
they have no belief but they still have
their way that they go about doing
things
this is their deen so the dean show here
that you're using people need to
understand that you're talking about the
dean
of the prophets the way of the lives of
the prophets
in particular prophet muhammad being the
last and the final messenger peace be
upon
him the succession
that they come in really isn't as
important
i think as knowing how each one of them
dealt with the type of problems they
were faced with
if we moved forward just a little bit on
the subject of abraham i don't want to
get too far away
that he has a relative by the name of
lute
which we pronounce lot with one o
it becomes if you put two o's it would
have been loot yeah but they put one oh
and
now today we pronounce it lot but the
prophet luke
alaihissalam peace be upon him and by
the way we we didn't mention this before
but after every time we say the name of
any prophet we're supposed to say
peace be upon him
or was the lama
something that would indicate that we're
giving this distinction to them
yes and lute
as a prophet was one who didn't have
scripture
now we said abraham did so if you want
to use that term we used in the first
program we said
super special human that would be
abraham would be super special because
not only he was a prophet
but he had scripture in the case of
lute he didn't have scripture but he was
a prophet
because he called to this right belief
by divine inspiration
now at his time the problem that he ran
into was that his people were disobeyed
in
him and they were engaged in some things
that were outside of
legal marriage not right to do and they
weren't married but they were having
these things that they did
and then enough to say that and so
these people are called the kamalute the
people of
lute they were bad they were disobedient
and when he called him
the right way they wouldn't listen and
without exception they were all really
bad people in these things that they did
they lived in a place which we call
sodom and gomorrah
and this is a famous place and today it
is said that the dead sea
is sitting on top of the very city of
loot and that if
you dive down there you would find it
there's so much uh
salt there though it's a it's more than
even the salt lake of
you know where salt lake city is that
everything is very buoyant
and there are people who have done some
diving there and tried to do some
excavation to try to get more
information about what's really there
for us it's enough just to know that
there were a people who were disobedient
we don't need to know for sure were they
really right there
did water really overtake them how were
they destroyed
what's important know is that they were
destroyed
because they're disobedient and not just
destroyed in this life
but they'll be in a horrible way in the
next life as well
what we learned in the first program and
every program we've talked about
is that a human being is a sinner
without exception
even our prophets they made some sins
not major sins though
never would we attribute a major sin to
them but they made mistakes human
mistakes
wrong doings we mentioned that about
jonah you remember
yes and jonah in the whale said
that all the glory is to a law and he
extelled the greatness of allah
and then he said the wrongdoing why i'm
in my condition now
is because of what i did to myself i'm
the wrong doer
so we find the prophets even prophet
muhammad peace be upon him said
i say a stuff for a law allah forgive me
more than a hundred times a day
so we see that all of us are sinners but
there is a way to be forgiven
that doesn't require some un
unbelievable gymnastics of thinking
you know mental uh stretch of the
imagination that you can't comprehend
or nor does it require for us to do
something
that is bloodletting or anything like
that but it's a matter of being really
sincere
in your repentance and saying that i'm
the wrong door and i need to be forgiven
for it
tell us how do we equate because we take
this information from authentic sources
we don't make things
up according to our desires well we hope
not to that
people still give their interpretation
of things you will never get away from
people even if you said i only want you
to quote the quran
yes and if i quote the quran you can say
well see he didn't give us anything of
his own opinion that would be a lie
because unless i quoted the quran from
the very first word to the
end in this case you could say well he
just quoted the quran
but by choosing verses to recite
and then choosing what order to recite
them in
and how i put emphasis on what i'm
reciting i can still
give my emotion to that and maybe you
perceive that one way or the other
tell us from what we see mention about
the prophet's
loot for instance okay in the bible
and some of the other prophets now when
you compare what's being
taught to us in islam what do you take
from that and what do you leave alone
well one of the things about lute for
instance is that when
the angels came to him we have the same
story
in islam that the angels came to him and
they were very beautiful and
handsome looking men and they they took
this kind of form
then the people of lut wanted to come
and do bad things with them
yeah and he refused to let them do that
now this would be the same but then
when lute leaves he goes out
a certain distance and as he's going out
the bible says his wife turned and
looked back and became a pillar of salt
but in reading the hebrew on that i
found that there's
different interpretations of what that
expression might have been or even what
the word might have been
it could be different manuscripts in
islam we know that
it wasn't that she turned back and
became salt rather
she did not go with him
and she became of those disbelievers and
she was destroyed by the fire that
they engulfed all of them the reason i
asked is because you mentioned that the
prophets
peace be upon all of them they didn't
commit major sins
but somebody might come from a christian
background
and he finds in the bible that some
major sins are attributed to the
prophets is this acceptable
we look in the quran and we find that
moses moses peace be upon him
killed the man yeah this is in the quran
that's a major sin
yes and that same sin is mentioned in
the
bible as well so that's that's a big sin
but we're going to say that that is not
by intent
because he wasn't trying to kill him he
was trying to hit him yeah
the fact that the man died makes it a
murder but it was never an
intent to kill it was an accident you
can't say it's an accident an accident
is like you turn around and just
accidentally
whack somebody you know or you're
backing up your car and drive over
somebody that'd be an accident yeah but
when you're hitting somebody
that is not an accident the fact they
died isn't what you wanted
so that it's a serious sin but we're
still not going to say it's the kind of
sin
that somebody set out to do yes this is
what will make something a major sin
real quick
that you're doing it blatantly you
wanted to do this thing and you did it
anyway
we mentioned about the devil and how he
refused to bow down
in front of god because of the creation
of adam
he refused he said i'm better than him i
won't bow down to this guy
i'm made from a smokeless fire and adam
is made from
this disgusting clay or
fluid or whatever so
that sin from him even though all he did
he just didn't bow down and eating fruit
for adam what kind of sin is that
it would have been a major sin it would
have been a horrible unforgivable sin
if he had not turned to a law in
repentance
so this is what it's about it's about
recognizing
the difference between making a sin
and not repenting even of something very
small
like eating something you shouldn't have
eaten or something small
like just not bowing down when you
should have bowed down
but that would not be a big thing if the
person said oh i didn't bow down i
better bow down. but it was the attitude
behind it yes this is one of the things
that makes it a real
major sin or even an unforgivable sin is
the attitude with which it was done
so you gave that example that there was
not
an intent to kill a person but some of
the other things that you might
find okay let us look to um
abraham peace be upon him he did an
example while he was traveling
when he went through egypt his wife was
with him and he was told that there was
a ruler at that time
who anytime he wanted a woman a
beautiful woman
that he would take her and if she's
married just kill the husband
so when some people came they
worked for the king and i guess they
were on the lookout for
cool chicks yeah i don't know and
he said to her tell them i'm your
brother
well that's a sin yeah and you could say
well
as we say in islam it wasn't actually a
falsehood because they were brother
and sister in islam
in faith they believe the same god and
so on so and brother and sister in faith
and brother and sister and sister coming
from adam we're all brothers and sisters
from adam we could you could say that
you're my brother in humanity
there's no doubt about it because we all
came from the same human being
but that's rationalization now
you're not admitting it but you lied
yeah so he lied
and said that he also broke those
people's statues
we mentioned that in another discussion
so these are things that would be
considered sins
but at the same time he did repent for
those things and he felt bad about it
now if you go and you look at the sin
where the things that
would be attributed to the prophets
where salute
was i see what you're saying okay
in the case of the story of luke the
whole thing was that these people were
doing some
illegal intercourse this is what they
were doing
yeah so after he's
escapes from all of that then according
to the bible story that they have
that lute is doing something is equal or
worse
by doing something with his own
daughters and this is just totally
bizarre and totally unacceptable to us
as muslims
we would say that this would disqualify
him then from being a prophet
because something that is done in the
context
of you know intercourse yes this is
not the same even as stealing something
because there can be no doubt that
what's being done here this is
every human knows better yes every human
knows that this is not done this is not
proper
and to engage in that would disqualify
so this would be unprofit-like
very definitely so disqualify you as
being a prophet
so that's in his case not something so
we don't accept
this absolutely absolutely not okay so
we talked about
lot now is there anything else that we
want to mention about him before we go
on to the next prophet
the prophet luke we don't have a whole
lot on him
as we might have for instance abraham is
mentioned so many times in the koran
as is moses musa as he's called in
arabic
peace be upon both of them you'll find
that
the importance isn't the person
but it is how they handled the
circumstances that they found themselves
in
whatever happens to them then what did
they do about it well they give a
message out and then this is the
rebuttal that came back and how did they
deal with it
and this is what really helps make them
stand out from the others
so he his consistent well his message is
consistent with the first man
that we talked about again surrender
submission sincerity obedience
and peace to the creator and he
was calling to the same thing so we have
a consistent chain
of them delivering the same message the
same way of life the same dean
calling people to worship the one god
not his creation who is the next
messenger that we want to talk about now
again i don't think it's important to go
in chronological order to say the one
who was born
next as some people might think that
that is irrelevant
and it may be for them but i think it's
important to look at the subject
matter that we're dealing with and we
were talking about being disobedient
with some very major sins here now in
the case
of one who has done some really big
mistakes what did they do about it we
could then go to
the prophet jonah we should talk about
him and he made a big mistake he left
his post
he was supposed to stay in neneva and
give a message to the people calling
them to the belief in one god
believing in one god and and being moral
and leave off the statue of worshipping
them but be moral good people
deal fair in business with each other
for instance
some of the prophets were sent to people
who didn't deal fair in
business and they were told this is
wrong you have to
deal fair then what did these prophets
do themselves
because if he called to a specific thing
he could not violate that even if he
repented it would be no good he wouldn't
be the example for that
so for sure we know that the prophets
who called to for instance
uh not dealing in bad business
transactions they themselves could not
have been guilty of that
the one who's calling people to the
correct
moral uh intercourse or sexual practices
they could not be guilty
of having committed that very same sin
uh-huh make sense
yes so we're almost out of time
not going in any chronological order who
would be the next prophet that
before we might like to speak about well
you could look to for instance
moses and we could give a whole program
just for moses
but one of the things about moses was
that you know he killed a person
this we know we've just discussed that
and his killing somebody and he left and
ranu off to another place this is also
mentioned in bible and quran
and for him to have killed somebody and
then run away
it might give people the idea that he
was running away from the sin of killing
somebody
but immediately he was repentant of what
he did
the reason he ran away is because he
knew that they would kill him
and it wasn't time for him to die so he
left
but when he did come back he had to
still face up to the fact that he had
killed somebody
yes and they did not
execute him but it certainly went bad
for him when he started calling them to
worship
one god how do you call us to worship a
god and you're a murderer
so this is i think a good comparison
here to look at
what can you tell us about moses his
life
that would resemble
some of the other prophets some of their
teachings
and the way of life now that he called
the people too
all of them called to the worship of one
god the belief that god is one do what
god wants you to do on his terms
no doubt at the same time not all of
them came with
scripture the way he did he was on tori
scene
or mount sinai where he received direct
revelation from almighty god
which he committed to writing it down
and brought down to his people when he
found them worshiping the golden calf
he lost his cool and he you know broke
these tablets he was really upset
because these people were in direct
opposition to the message he was coming
with
and they had fallen back on the false
worship of the gods
that the egyptians had been worshipped
so was he a
a person who was following
because the jews the jew the
children of israel israel yeah they
would consider him their
prophet so was he preaching judaism
or christianity he was preaching the
message that he got on
mount sinai that's what he was preaching
was that again that surrender
submission obedience sincerity
and peace which is some doubt but it had
commandments with it
yeah yeah now if you want to go in
chronological order though
after abraham you would go immediately
to his son
he had a son by the name of ishmael or
ismail ishmael
and he was a prophet after abraham and
then he had another son
ishak or isaac in english again
another prophet they were both prophets
and the problems between their mothers
is another subject
but one lived with his father which was
isaac the other one was left in the
desert with his mother
at a place called bacca and becca's
mentioning genesis
sounds like mecca well becca is also the
name used in the quran to describe the
old name
of mecca it became known as makkah
that's where we make the pilgrimage
right exactly that is the place actually
there's a lot about that we didn't even
talk about the
what happened with his son when he
received the dream
and this was a a prophetic dream that he
was to sacrifice his son
now he waited almost what 90 years
something like that before he ever had a
child this is an amazing thing
now he has a child and he's being told
by allah in a dream
to sacrifice his son when he tried to do
it
the knife wouldn't cut his son it
wouldn't wouldn't
uh you know sever his neck or anything
so
allah was testing him yeah and then a
ram was
came up a a male sheep and they
slaughtered that instead
so we can see this consistent way of
life that all the messengers are living
they're
striving to be humbly obedient to the
commands of their creator
sometimes it's easier for some people
than it is others yeah
but that's exactly true yeah well we're
almost coming to
a close if you can before we go on and
we have a few more messengers that we
want to cover we want to talk about
possibly jesus and the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad
in some upcoming shows but if there's
any closing
comments and advice that you want to
give one of the prophets that came after
abraham
there was abraham ismail isaac from
isaac
or ishaq comes one whose name is
jacob we call him jacob
jacob became israel and israel is the
progenitor of
all of the 12 tribes and from them came
all the rest of the people
one of the sons of israel or jacob is
named
yehud or judah
and it's for him that many people say it
comes the name
judaism because he's the oldest son
of israel this was a prophet some say he
was what was his name
judah judah some say it was a prophet
although according to islam it doesn't
appear to be
this is for anybody why because joseph
or yusuf that i'm named after is
definitely a prophet definitely without
a doubt
we didn't talk about him where does he
fit in this
coming after he has some amazing story
that goes along with him you can read it
in the bible in genesis there's a whole
section for him
but also in the quran itself chapter 12
is called
surah yusuf you can read the whole
chapter it's very interesting they're
almost parallel
except when you get toward the end and
you see some very good lessons
in the quran that are missed somehow in
the bible
i mean for any sincere individual who
just uses the tools that the creator has
given them this
brain and he uses what god had put
inside of this
inclination to worship god you will see
i mean that these
men are known through history and they
came with that consistent message to
worship the one god
so if somebody says how would you
respond
i've heard this argument that when you
mention prophets and god that this is a
way for the elite the rich
just to control the poor so they give
them this kind of
story and these things that we're
talking about how would you repeat this
quickly
it's true that people have done that
very serious
uh subject that people have manipulated
other people by
presenting a religion they made up or
corrupting the religion that did come
with real prophets
trying to emphasize certain things or
exaggerate
or be little or perhaps
add to or take away from in a way that
they could manipulate the people's money
their wealth in general or the power
over the society
the political aspects that go along with
it this is well known
people have done that and this is why
god keeps sending new prophets
and sending in the new message the same
message but it looks new to the people
because they've lost the original yes
yeah but
and this happened so many times but when
the quran came allah
promised to protect it and he has we
still have it exactly
today as it was 1400 years ago that's
why it wasn't necessary for any new
prophet to come after him yeah
where can people if they want more
information you have a website that
people can
have one really nice website for people
want to learn something about the quran
itself
it's called allah's quran don't put an
apostrophe it won't work on there
just a-l-l-a-h-s-q-u-r-a-n.com
allah's quran dot com and in the cover
page gives you a nice story about the
quran and some basics
you can also read the quran or have it
read to you
there are links for read or listen or
even learn the quran
and how to recite it and everything from
the arabic all of that's available on
that website
thank you jazakallahu may the creator
allah reward you for being with us here
today
and thank you for being with us for
another episode of the dean show
you can catch up and come up to speed
and see
all the other shows that we've done with
sheik estes at thedeenshow.com
where we talked about the first prophet
adam
and some of the other prophets and today
the prophets that we talked about
and you can see the consistent message
that all of them came with
that way that way of submitting
surrendering
sincerely in obedience and in peace to
the one god to the one creator
and this is summed up with one word
islam
so if you liked what we had to talk
about here today you can come and visit
us every week here at thedeenshow.com
and we'll see you next time inshallah
god willing assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you
foreign
foreign
the dvds for dawah as allah has said in
the quran in surah
16 125
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best
and this is a great opportunity for you
to take up the obligation take up
the call as allah has told you to do and
share this beautiful message
with the world islam submission to the
one god
come and see what everyone's talking
about if you find one contradiction it
can't be from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best
give up worshiping god is one i will
never give up spreading this message
i hope that you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're going to live
till tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim it attended our
faith too
it's cold it's late
everybody sleeping
i arise
and ask a lot of thinking may
oh allah you see
oh allah you know
all the sins i do
i turn to you to forgive my sins and my
heart
i'm
me